it's only in times of deep crisis that
the country imposes a 30-day state of
emergency
and that's what president vladimir
zelinsky asked parliament for wednesday
after sharing a meeting of his security
council
zelensky also hosted his polish and
lithuanian counterparts the three
signing a joint declaration of support
and solidarity
police president andres duda described
russia's actions as a threat not just to
ukraine but to the whole eu
zelensky said it is russia that should
be providing security guarantees not the
other way round
the fact is that today there are 150 000
russian soldiers at our border those
territories are temporarily occupied
i believe that russia should be among
those countries that provide clear
security guarantees it's not a secret
that i have many times suggested that
the president of russia sit down at the
negotiating table and speak
in the west intense shuttle diplomacy
continues france's foreign minister has
been in berlin for talks
and tougher sanctions are looking
inevitable
we accept economic consequences for free
sovereign and democratic ukraine peace
and freedom in europe have no price tag
ukraine welcomed the long-awaited
sanctions even though its foreign
minister dimitro coleba asked for more
posting on social media
hit more hit hard and hit now in the
donbas
the situation along the demarcation line
is becoming more tense by day
shelling is reported by both sides
in eastern ukraine the leader of one of
the rebel regions now recognized by
russia said he wants to peacefully
settle its borders however dennis
butcherlin
added that he may need russia's help
at the moment there is no presence of
any russian troops on our soil as for
the future presence that is likely when
it's needed if we are not able to do
with our own resources then we may seek
support from the russians
his words were received as a warning to
people living in the donetsk and luhans
regions taken by the separatists at the
beginning of the war but now under
ukrainian control
separatist leaders have made public
their territorial ambitions saying that
both the dunyas and against regions
should return under their control
that has increased the worry among
people living even far away from the
contact line
that fighting will return to their
hometowns
al jazeera from outdoors in eastern
ukraine